ne connaît que les élus du suffrage
universel la politique de la famille
quatre grandes directions
invité de notre journal madame simone
veil -le ministre de la santé de la
famille le monopole de la radio et de la
télé à l'assemblée jean philippe lecat
notre projet défend la liberté mundial
21h40 franc direct sur antenne 2
hollande pérou la messieurs bonsoir
france capitale ajaccio depuis 4 heures
et pendant trois jours la tête du
pouvoir s'est installé en corse avec la
visite du chef de l'état le chef de
l'état qui il y a quatre ans tout juste
alors candidat à l'elysée avait dit au
corps souvenez vous de moi et je me
souviendrai de voyages clandestins et
donc dans l'île de beauté pour écouter
pour parler mais son arrivée d'ailleurs
il a proclamé de oui et un non aux
insulaires oui à la prospérité
oui à la sécurité pour les corses mais
refus pour l'état de connaître d'autres
interlocuteurs que ceux élus par le
suffrage universel
ça c'est pour les autonomistes et
l'autonomiste qui sont décimés depuis
quelques jours aujourd'hui 24 personnes
déférées devant la cour de sûreté de
l'état
prenons donc au voyage présidentiel avec
nos envoyés spéciaux en corse est
d'abord le premier discours du président
l'essentiel c'est que la france dans le
respect de la personnalité des terroirs
mais dans l'affirmation de l'unité
nationale poursuit une oeuvre de
développement de progrès et de justice
avec la participation active de la
population et des élus
cette oeuvre elle entend la conduire
avec les corses ma deuxième affirmation
est simple mais elle est solennel l'état
démocratique l'état républicain dans
lequel nous avons la fierté de vivre ne
connaît dans la préparation des
décisions qui s'appliquent à une
fraction du territoire que les élus du
suffrage universel et populaire
lorsque le suffrage s'exprime
démocratiquement au terme d'une
consultation libre et intense
il est la seule expression légitime de
leurs aspirations
sur ce point à mes yeux les choses sont
claires on ne récuse pas le suffrage
universel
on ne joue pas qu'à ska avec la libre
expression de la volonté des citoyens
enfin enfin les cordes les femmes et les
hommes de corse
comme tous les français ont droit à la
sécurité dans leur personne et dans
leurs biens
c'est un droit fondamental que la
république vous assurera selon ses
moyens et ses lois ses propos je vous
tiens ne s'applique pas seulement à la
corse
il s'applique à la république française
toute entière
je n'ai pas en tenir d'autres en tant
que responsable de l'unité de la nation
et défenseur naturel des lois de la
république
l'unité nationale c'est le thème central
de la première allocution de valéry
giscard d'estaing un discours politique
je crois qu'on peut qualifier de très
faire le chef de l'état a rappelé
d'emblée qu'il était responsable de
l'unité de la nation et le défenseur des
lois de la république
un rappel qui vous en doutez prend ici
une signification toute particulière
alors au désir d'une certaine autonomie
régionale
il a apporté une réponse très claire le
suffrage universel est la seule
expression d inspiration c'est le seul
interlocuteur
je vous rappelle qu'il arrive dans une
région qui a élu aux dernières élections
législatives quatre députés rpr
c'est donc clair ici ce soir le chef de
l'état ne tiendra pas compte de
l'agitation ni même du malaise provoqué
iba un attentat en moyenne chaque jour
depuis le début de l'année mais plus
encore il ne veut pas donner à la corse
aucune autre région en france ne possède
c'est à dire le pouvoir régional
l'identité corse pour valéry giscard
d'estaing c'est l'amour que chaque homme
a pour sa terre et en cela elle ne
diffère en rien de l'identité française
malgré ces efforts méritoires pour
rendre la vie brillante en l'honneur de
valéry giscard d'estaing la municipalité
d'ajaccio n'a pas réussi à avoir le
concours d'un beau et franc soleil on
s'est donc contenté d'une luminosité
voile et le chef de l'état après son
discours sur la place foch est allé
décoré de la légion d'honneur le maire
d'ajaccio monsieur charles ornano dans
les salons napoléonien de l'hôtel de
ville
et puis enfin au balcon il a reçu une
franche acclamations plus éclatante que
celle qui peu avant avaient ponctué son
discours
valéry giscard d'estaing devait terminer
son après-midi y en admirant au musée
fesch la collection unique des oeuvres
des primitifs italiens avant d'aller
s'entretenir en privé avec les élus
corses à la préfecture des élus qui ont
tout lieu ce soir d'être satisfaits et
rassurés puisqu'ils ont été fermement
réaffirmé comme les seuls interlocuteurs
valables porte parole
exclusif de la volonté populaire le
président veut néanmoins voir les choses
de plus près il visitera demain matin
trois localités du sud de la corse
ton certaines chef lieu d'arrondissement
et c'est demain après midi qu'il
annoncera devant le conseil régional à
ajaccio un certain nombre de mesures
destinées à améliorer le sort de l'île
des mesures qui toucheront au domaine
des transports maritimes et aériens au
problème du développement économique
avec un chapitre spécial en faveur de
l'artisanat ciel de corse est décidément
très convoité en ce moment quelques
heures avant l'arrivée du chef de l'état
s'était les légionnaires partie de call
wazi qui faisaient leur retour la base
de calvi la plupart des paras du 2e rep
sont en effet revenus par vagues
successives trois compagnies sur quatre
parallèlement d'ailleurs les six ans par
appel stationner chabar reviennent
progressivement au fur et à mesure de
leur remplacement par des troupes
interafricaine essentiellement pour
l'instant marocaine dans l'un des avions
des légionnaires français
deux de nos journalistes françois cornet
et roland tout
mardi matin 6h30 sur l'aéroport de
lubumbashi le ballet aérien des
appareils de l'us air force a commencé
les parachutistes français d'un côté les
soldats marocains de l'autre qui
viennent assurer la relève des bérets
verts
au milieu de ses hommes les mécaniciens
de piste de l'armée de l'air américaine
tout semble avoir été mise en place pour
le tournage d'une super production des
hommes des uniformes des avions il ya
même un petit chien dans la musette dans
légionnaires que l'on surnomme kolwezi
le 2e rep quitte le zaïre
il ne s'est pas enlisée comme certains
le redoutaient dans cette nouvelle
guerre du shabbat
conformément au plan prévu
ce contingent marocain un millier et
demi d'hommes s'est substituée à lui des
renforts sénégalais et gabonais
devraient suivre sur ses terres au port
de l'ancien elisabeth ville le spectacle
du départ de ces bérets verts a serré le
coeur de bien des européens
certes on s'y attendait à lubumbashi
mais je ne croyais pas que les choses
iraient aussi vite
on s'était même installé dans une
certaine euphorie depuis l'arrivée de la
légion que va-t-il se passer maintenant
c'est bien sûr la grande inconnue
ou bien les cadres européens vont suivre
le corps expéditionnaire français et qui
tel zaïre
ou bien ils resteront éviteront
l'asphyxient de la production du cuivre
et sauveront l'économie zaïroise du
désert
leur protection est maintenant assurée
par l'armée marocaine qui connaît bien
le chabat et le piège de l'intervention
française au zaïre ne s'est pas refermée
sur le deuxième rêve avec le départ de
cet appareil de l' us air force pour son
embarras l'opération fonck thuel de la
légion chabat est terminée elle portait
le nom de léopard elle avait commencé le
19 mai à 15h10 avec le parachutage de
ses hommes sur kolwezi
elle aura donc duré 18 jours le premier
appareil de l us air force s'est posée
la nuit dernière à solenzara
le pont aérien entre le boom bachy à la
corse doit se terminer demain
jimmy carter lui même a évoqué il ya
quelques heures la situation au zaïre
dans un discours qu'il a prononcé dans
le maryland
nous sommes toujours très préoccupés par
les initiatives soviéto cubaine at il
dit en substance
et nous ferons tout pour aider les
africains aller contre car elle sauvée
d'une union ou la conférence
présidentielle est un président sur
l'afrique n'ont quitté cuba est très
clairement déclaré que les états unis
soutiendraient les pays africains un ac
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale à
l'étranger toujours en reste à sion les
auteurs de l'attentât dans le métro de
moscou il ya un an et demi ça use doigté
soviétique ne donnent pas non mais
laisse entendre que des dissidents
seraient mises en cause et certains
disques d'autres attentats auraient
suivi dans divers endroits de la
capitale soviétique
antonio bella vita ne sera pas extradé
en italie ainsi en a décidé la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de paris
le journaliste italien était accusé de
connivence avec hydro
enfin une question de françois
mitterrand au gouvernement le leader
socialiste lui demande d'intervenir
auprès du général pinochet en faveur des
prisonniers politiques au chi toujours à
l'assemblée le dossier des radios
locales et des radios libres aujourd'hui
en fait il s'agit d'une extension à un
débat qui initialement devait se limiter
à un point de détail comment juridique
un détail qui avait son importance
prévoir des sanctions en cas de
violation du monopole radiotélévisée
jusqu alors la loi n'avait rien prévu et
cela permettait le foisonnement de
diverses radios commerciales ou le plus
souvent look à celle émise de la
communication jean philippe lecat qui
s'est chargé de défendre le point de vue
du gouvernement face au désir croissant
des besoins locaux
j'ai dit n'est ce pas que ce désir
d'expression localisé et est en effet
quelque chose de réel de sérieux j'ai
exposé le travail qui est fait par fr3
par radio france qui est peu connu peu
de gens savent qu'il y a près de 25
mille heures de radio régionale et que
ces radios donne en réalité déjà un
certain nombre de satisfactions au
public
faut-il aller au delà c'est la grande
question que pose ce débat comme
d'ailleurs l'avait posé le débat au
sénat
il ya quinze jours à propos des
questions orales des sénateurs cluzel et
caillavet vous avez pu remarquer que
personne n'est d'accord sur la formule à
laquelle il faudrait recourir
on veut se garder de la privatisation on
veut se garder de l'italian isation de
l'anarchie on veut se garder de toutes
sortes de dangers
je pense que l'heure est à la réflexion
et le gouvernement s'est engagé
aujourd'hui à conduire avec le parlement
cette réflexion nécessaire bien avec
nous en direct de l'assemblée daniel
brême pour essayer de nous donner un
compte-rendu de cette journée alors
beaucoup de journalistes dans les
tribunes de presse assez normal daniel
mais aussi la tribune oui
on avait au moins c'est que monsieur
thaci monsieur khalid monsieur leroi
monsieur filloux et sans oublier
évidemment michel péricard et je suis
sûr que j'en oublie mais voyez vous ce
qu'est ont été remarqués aujourd'hui
comme chaque fois qu'on parle de radio
et de télévision
et bien c'est que ce débat ne peut
jamais se passer sans patient et on
s'est envoyé quelques aménité à la tête
par exemple monsieur filou a dit au
gouvernement
vous partez en guerre entre les petits
pirates des radios libres mais vous
installez vos hommes dans les sièges des
groupes irak comme en europe 1 aimanté
cas réplique immédiate de monsieur
chesneau de l'udf et monsieur fillion ou
lorsque vous étiez journaliste europe
numéro un vous serviez des pirates
vous avez mis du temps à vous en
apercevoir et on a appelé à un grand
renfort les citations de monsieur
mitterrand 49 de monsieur rocard en 72
et même de montaigne pour défendre le
monopole en ça c'est amusant daniel ça
nous intéresse nous journalistes mais
sur le fond maintenant eh bien monsieur
leroi communiste comme monsieur fillon
ont reproché avec beaucoup de véhémence
au gouvernement de se servir du monopole
à son profit exclusif et de nous
transformer nous les journalistes en
perroquet de l'audiovisuel alors au
milieu de tout cet orage monsieur le cas
avec beaucoup de bonhomie a fait
observer que si l'article qu'il
demandait à l'assemblée de voter pour
punir les infractions monopole et bien
n'était pas voté cette nuit tout le
monopole votre et en éclats ce qui
ouvrirait la porte à tous les abus et à
tous les débordements comme en italie
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure qu'il
ne ferme pas la porte à la possibilité
de radio locale à l'intérieur du service
public donc je ne reviendrai pas sur ce
problème mais sur ce plan il y à de
fortes pressions et chacun à la dans la
majorité comme dans l'opposition
conçoit ses radios d'une façon qui n'est
évidemment pas la même bien gagner l'on
retrouve dans le dernier journal avec
les interventions des différents
orateurs donc vers 23 heures deux têtes
de chapitre pour le conseil des
ministres de ce matin d'abord le point
par le ministre de l'intérieur sur le
plan de développement des
responsabilités locales
un plan qui modifiera les rapports entre
les citoyens le pouvoir a dit le chef de
l'état a n'a que deux fois dans l'année
grassi un projet de loi sera déposé au
sénat au début de la prochaine session
d'automne un projet de loi cadre
et puis un autre dossier plus public
celui là la politique de la famille du
gouvernement telles qu'elles découlent
des promesses du programme de blois il
faut savoir qu'un revenu familial
garantie de 3500 francs sera institué
avant la fin de l'année prochaine pour
les familles d'au moins trois enfants
savoir aussi que pour ces mêmes familles
les prestations familiales atteindrons
dans un an au 1er juillet 79 donc un
minimum de 1000 francs par mois
là il faut bien faire la distinction
entre le revenu familial et prestations
familiales
dans le cas du revenu il s'agit du
salaire plus les prestations familiales
savoir ensuite que le statut de la mère
de famille et de la veuve sera améliorée
et qu'en fait les conditions de vie des
mères de famille qui travaille seront
aménagés
alors avec vous avec nous donc simone
veil je vous pose un certain nombre de
questions il faut évidemment seriez dans
cette grande politique familiale du
gouvernement et à l'abord ce congé
maternité dont on a annoncé la semaine
dernière qu'il était porté de 14 à 16
semaines
est ce que il n'ya pas le risque pour
les employeurs de prétexter de ça pour
disons avoir délivré une embauche pour
les femmes pensent que c'est plus
difficile pour une femme désormais oui
alors je crois que dans la perspective
actuelle de ce prolongement décidé et
qui sera souvent décidé pour l'instant
et qui doit être soumis dès la semaine
prochaine au sénat
il n'y a guère de risque car on passe de
14 à 16 semaines ça n'est pas très
important comme augmentation comme
pénalisation je dirais par rapport à
l'emploi vous pensé aller plus loin a
lieu alors le programme de bois lui-même
que vous avez évoqué prévoit trois mois
comme congé de maternité
évidemment état de cette mesure devant
être étalés sur lens sur le l'ensemble
d'une forme de moi c'est à dire sur
quatre en 1981 mais ce que je voudrais
souligner c'est que pour les modalités
de ce congé qui aura donc trois mois
supplémentaires y compris les quinze
jours qui vont intervenir tout de suite
nous allons étudier très attentivement
les modalités pour que les jeunes femmes
ne sont pas pénalisés et nous nous
concerterons avec bien sûr les
partenaires sociaux les syndicats le
patronat également avec les associations
féminines qui sont préoccupés par cette
question est qui
souhaite que l'on fasse attention
justement à ce que cela puisse concilier
les possibilités d'embauché pour les
fans tout en leur donnant cette
amélioration très importants et par
exemple une des modalités qui est
envisagé pour ce congé c'est le
fractionnement car je pense que ce sera
plus facile pour les femmes travaillant
de l'assumer de le faire accepter par
l'employeur ce que je reste la chose sur
laquelle il est important d'insister
c'est que nous ne prendrons pas comme ça
une mesure avec sa propre tôt mais
uniquement après en avoir discuté avec
les intérêts sinon pour en revenir
maintenant au cadre plus général de
votre politique familiale est ce que
c'est une politique vraiment natalys
comme le réclament certains michel debré
par exemple je crois qu'il est d'abord
très difficile de séparer politique
nataliste et politique de justice
sociale et politique familiale les trois
vont ensemble ont des objectifs communs
et doivent être harmonisés par exemple
la politique nataliste on peut dire
c'est une petite taille ce coup fait
puisque vous favorisez particulièrement
les familles de trois enfants
avec ces deux mesures très importantes
dont vous avez parlé qui devront entrer
en application dans le courant de
l'année 1979 où la fin 1979 qui sont les
allocations familiales cette portée à
1000 francs pour les fans de trois
enfants qui n'ont pas encore et puis
surtout l'heureuse mesures très
importantes le revenu minimum garanti à
3500 à 4500 vous paraît assez solitaire
prothèse alors je crois que c'est pour
beaucoup de familles qui actuellement
sont dans une situation de grande
faiblesse par exemple lorsque 1 s'il ya
un seul parent ou bien quand le seul
parent qui travaillaient est inapte au
travail les tapis de pension ce sera une
amélioration très en avance ce sera je
dirais une sécurité considérable de
savoir qu'on ne peut pas tomber en
dessous de ce minimum et là je dois dire
que l'on peut vous dire c'est une
politique inattendue dire que avant tout
c'est une politique de justice sociale
parce que bien sûr nous favorisons
partie commencée famille de trois
enfants
mais ce sont elles sont les charges les
plus lourdes et c'est donc une
compensation que des charges familiales
et donc que ça rejoint je crois les
trois objectifs à la formation
le conflit renault maintenant c'est
demain que le travail doit en principe
reprendre à flins en tout cas l usine
sera réouverte ça après l'évacuation
hier matin des grévistes qui l'occupait
et syndicats ont décidé d'appeler le
travailleur à un nouveau débrayage
demain matin de même d'ailleurs qu'à
sandouville aujourd'hui et au mans pour
la première fois aujourd'hui également
et pendant ce temps l'usiné de cléon
elle reste toujours occupée un huissier
est venu constater cette occupation
peu de temps après l'expiration du délai
qui avait fixé le tribunal des référés
droit pour autant cgt cfdt tiennent pas
le même langage et ne cachent pas leurs
divergences sur la stratégie à suivre
voilà
nous devrons continuer nous devons
continuer notre action telle qu'elle ait
démarré grève de 24 heures reconductible
avec occupation car une nouvelle fois la
direction montre son refus et son
intransigeance à cléon de discuter la
cfdt a dit ce matin qu'elle n'était pas
favorable à l'occupation de l'usiné de
cléon contrairement le cgt pourquoi
alors nous avons pas d'hostilité
l'occupation de l'usiné de cléon nous
pensons à la cfdt que c'est pas la
meilleure forme d'actions dans la
situation du moment adapté à la
situation de l'entreprise et que
l'objectif pour la cfdt
c'est de faire que les 110 mille
travailleurs du groupe passe à l'action
sur leurs revendications qui sont les
mêmes que les travailleurs de cléon on
ne peut pas tolérer à la cfdt que 500
travailleurs seulement sur 110 milles
défendre les revendications de
l'ensemble du groupe c'est bien
l'objectif qu'on veut poursuivre qu'on a
proposé à nos camarades de la société
qui ont refusé cette moyens c'est
d'étendre l'action à l'ensemble du
groupe sous des formes diversifiées
puisque tous les tours toutes les usines
du groupe ne sont pas prêts à passer
alors à l'occupation
la direction de la régie elle réaffirme
sa fermeté en refusant de recevoir une
délégation syndicale pas de négociations
avant le retour au calme était en
substance
et face à cette attitude les divergences
de la cgt de la cfdt vont handicaper
cette action syndicale dont on ne sait
toujours pas s'il faut l'interpréter
comme un signe avant coureur d'un orage
social à venir
la cgt qui craignaient d'être isolé par
le recentrage de la cfdt est peut être
tenté d'utiliser ce conflit pour essayer
de forcer la main la cfdt et lui faire
abandonner sa politique de négociation
en fixant la part des revendications un
niveau élevé 3000 francs de salaire
minimum cinquième semaine de congés
payés la cgt d'un également un tour
politique à ce conflit
et c'est la raison pour laquelle à ce
but et reste sur des positions prudentes
il semble impossible pour le moment de
prévoir quelle sera l'évolution du
conflit renault mais il semble que
d'autres conflits sont en préparation
dans le secteur nationalisé à la sncf
notamment
quant aux milices de l'industrie andré
giroux il estime que les gravissent de
cléon sont une infime minorité c'est ce
qu'il a répliqué tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée aux orateurs qui
l'interpellaient le socialiste michel
rocard et le communiste roland l'ordre
manufrance c'est demain que le pdg
françois gado clé sera reçue au
ministère l'économie pour déposer son
plan de redressement
mise en liberté de roger leleu cet
ancien pdg incarcéré depuis une semaine
pour entrave à la liberté syndicale
c'est ce qu'a ordonné aujourd'hui la
cour d'appel de douai justice toujours à
paris cette fois avec beaucoup de monde
autour du palais de justice autour de
justin de rech savoir que je signerai
chez l'ami de jacques mesrine et qu'il y
avait beaucoup de forces de l'ordre
autour d'elle elle comparaissait pour
quelques broutilles petites peines de
prison elle sera libre dans quelques
jours j'en viens maintenant au sport
avec le tennis ou d'abord jolie
performance pour la française brigitte
simon qui s'est qualifiée ce matin
roland garros pour les demi finales des
internationaux de france
côté côté messieurs pardon l'américain
stockton a triomphé de l'espagnol or en
baisse en quatre manches et l'argentin
ville assez sérieusement accroché en ce
moment même par le chilien deal de
maëster ils en sont au cinquième set et
tout à l'heure il ya une minute à peine
on me téléphoner de roland garros pour
me dire que villa selon forfait 5 à 3
dans ce cinquième set
le résultat définitif dans ce journal et
puis football bien sûr l'aventuré fini
pour le onze tricolore fini mais bien
fini tout est perdu fors l'honneur
l'équipe de france a été vaincu hier par
les argentins vous êtes des millions à
avoir vécu ce petit drame nous ont dit
les ingénieurs de l'edf qui ont vu une
montée anormal de consommation
d'électricité à partir de 00h15 par jour
de revivre les grands moments de ce
match qui devait dans le conduire à
l'humiliation de français de la coupe du
monde
dernière minute
première mi-temps et premier malheur des
français sur cette action les argentins
vont obtenir un penalty ambulants font
très lookée des heures sombres et pousse
le ballon de la main
après avoir consulté son juge de touche
l'arbitré suisse monsieur du bac accorde
le bénin alors revoyons cette action
ralenti certes leur touche le ballon de
la main mais la faute est elle vraiment
intentionnel bertrand demande se
concentre passarella lui ne se pose pas
de question et transforme imparablement
1 0 pour la revente lisier minutes de la
deuxième mi-temps nouveau coup dur pour
les français look et va effectuer un
excellent tir des 30 mètres
les voici bertrand demanes dévie en
corner mais en retrouvant une surf
violemment aux poteaux à l'hôpital la
radio ne révèlent rien de grave
sur le terrain dominique baratelli le
remplace dans l'île
les pensées vont pourtant égalisé six
minutes plus tard sur une remarquable
action de bernard lacombe
regardez
bofill à leurs yeux la barre en bois
lacombe récupère mais les sources date
ni qui égalise un but pas et le ralenti
lacombe
à log magnifique sur la barre lacombe
est là pour récupérer et il laisse à
venir cela qu'il est mieux placé 25e
minute balle de match pour les français
platini en profondeur pour 6 et
malheureusement à côté
revoici mais si le tir de six étaient
moins croisé fillol l'aurait
probablement des tombes
trois minutes plus tard les argentins
vont marquer qu'un baisse hardy laisse
look et personne ne l'attaquent alors
gentiment nous a vus se sentir
2 1 pour l'argentine c'est le but de la
victoire avec quatre points l'argentine
qualifiée tout comme ils s'allient 20
heures l'après midi le dollar ou au
ralenti revoici ce but qui élimine
développement la france
l'erreur de marquage facilite grandement
la tâche
alou les pensées qu'il donc la coupe du
monde autant il s'était laissé malmené
par l'italie autant ils se sont bien
battus hier reste à rencontrer la
hongrie une victoire pour l'honneur
peut-on lui à tennis finalement vilas a
gagné médicaux crespo 6 3 dans le
cinquième set face à gildemeister loto
il y avait un tirage comme chaque
mercredi aussi les six numéros le18 le
13 le 21 le 35 et le 43 numéro
complémentaire le 24 avant de refermer
ce journal la météo comme chaque soir
beaucoup de nuages aujourd'hui sur la
france accompagné de pluies orageuses
peu de changements ce qui concernait
température demain encore de la pluie
surtout sur les régions méditerranéennes
et sur le sud est
voici la carte de demain ailleurs un
temps brumeux et vous voyez franchement
nuage eux-mêmes en fin de soirée vers
23h30 c'est donc bernard rapp qui vous
présentera la dernière édition je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de soirée l
écoute de nos programmes
bonsoir à tous à demain